can you take supplements or do they
activate your AI disease I kind of like
that activate your AI disease can I take
supplements no so I can take unflavored
electrolytes which is why I'm making a
version for people that's just sodium
potassium magnesium and nothing else and
if I'm fasting or even intermittent
fasting that makes me feel better
there's one other thing I can take
barely I've tried like I got covered a
couple of times so this diet wasn't like
now I never get sick I have a toddler
she gets to be sick all the time so I
don't get like deathly ill or anything
and covid was fine it was covid but I
did get it three times I traveled around
a lot though um no anyway I was getting
I was in Tennessee last year okay so we
moved to Tennessee and I've got terrible
tree allergies and the diets helped my
environmental allergies but it has not
gotten rid of my environmental allergies
for sure I am so allergic to everything
it's crazy and I used to be so allergic
to everything that I was dying now I'm
just so allergic to everything but in
Tennessee I was getting sick and I was
getting bronchitis where repeatedly and
I was like what is happening I feel like
I'm a kid again because that used to
happen all the time when I was a kid my
daughter was getting bronchitis all the
time and it was because tree allergies
in Tennessee were so severe it brought
back my asthma so I tried to take zinc
out of like desperationals like maybe
zinc will stop me from getting sick this
is before I knew it was tree allergies
exacerbating the asthma giving me
bronchitis whenever I got a cold even
honey I can't sleep if I take that at
night I can't take zinc I can't really
take Vitamin C at night the only things
I can kind of take I can take a little
bit of vitamin C just for like the sour
flavor just to get some flavor that
seems to be fine I just don't take it at
night and then I take this when I drink
you're like oh no she drinks how could
she drink so I don't drink very often I
used to drink way more when I was sick I
drank so much I don't drink very often
because the hangovers are just brutal
when you don't have any carbs and I get
tired when I drink now it used to
energize me when I was sick and now I
just get tired so I don't drink very
often but when I do drink I drink vodka
I like Tito's or Bourbon and those are
the only two hard alcohols that I'm
aware of where they don't add extra
ingredients after distilling so gin they
add Botanicals after distilling Scotch a
lot of the time they add caramel
coloring they don't in Bourbon it's just
distilled vodka it's just distilled
unless you're in Russia and then they
add sugar and Botanicals like gin
Silver Tequila also no ingredients added
after distillation so those three
alcohols Silver Tequila Bourbon and
vodka that isn't Russian they don't give
me any autoimmune symptoms they just
give me a severe hangover and for those
hangovers I take a supplement called
dihydromyrocitin which I'm also
producing because I've been taking it
for like 10 years when I drink way
before I started dieting which is why I
know it works I'll get into it a little
bit they did this it's because it's it's
I think it's funny when I was 20 I was
dying from a hangover and from being
unbelievably ill and I was like how can
it be 20 what I guess 12. how can we not
have a hangover cure it's 2012. and so I
started researching and I found this
herb called dihydramy riceeten and I
looked at the study and it was a study
done on rats so what they did to these
poor rats is they just pumped them full
of alcohol so they had rats that were
pumped full of alcohol and then the rats
that were pumped full of alcohol and
dihydromy-racetin and they ran tests on
them so one of the tests was you drop
them in water and you see which one just
gives up faster so the rat that had
alcohol and dihydromyricetin swam longer
significantly longer than the rat that
was just drunk they did another test
where you just put the rats on their
back and see which one flips over faster
and the rot with dihydromy rust and
flipped over faster and then the third
test was they ran rats through a maze so
hung over rats will just kind of like
shiver in a corner instead of going to
get the cheese or whatever the treat is
in the Maze and rats given
dihydramarisotin so rather than being
hungover they had they were hungover
with dihydramy-racetin they weren't as
shivery and scared and they went to get
the treat faster so I read that study
and I was like well that sounds like me
when I'm hungover shivering in a corner
I started trying to buy this dihydroma
rice tin which was very difficult to
find and then I spent a couple years
figuring out what dose to take anyway
I've made it into a supplement called
after party which is launching soon so I
do take that but I only take it when I'm
drinking it helps break down
acetaldehyde which is the toxic
byproduct of alcohol and it works weekly
on Gaba so part of what alcohol does is
it desensitizes your Gaba receptors
that's part of what it does right floods
your brain with some gavel which makes
you feel good and then the next day
you're kind of anxious because your
receptors are a little desensitized it
works weekly on Gaba so it works in two
ways helps you detoxify by breaking down
acetaldehyde and it works weekly on Gaba
if you take it at a high enough dose a
lot of the supplements on the market are
low dose and they just don't work anyway
that's coming out soon so I do take that
supplement but that has nothing to do
with my autoimmune disorder that's just
because occasionally I drink and
drinking is bad for you so you probably
shouldn't do it which means you don't
need the supplement the only supplement
I take that's actually for the diet is
electrolytes and I don't take them very
often anymore but I should have taken
them more at the beginning of the diet
there that was a long and drawn out
answer
[Music]